парламент знищений ніхто як ви не множив
на ноль парламентаризм євроінтеграцією
зайнялись тільки коли вже петух клюнул в
одне місце на державному бюджеті
сьогодні стають новими курченками друзі
Всіх вітаю це Верховна Рада України і
велика ганьба що 170 мльні гривень
виділяється на канал Рада але парламент
він не показує тому що відданий в лізинг
офісу президента безумовно ви абсолютно
праві тому Ми продовжуємо наші
парламентські хроніки і розповідаємо вам
про найважливіше з роботи Верховної Ради
[музика]
України парламент нарешті проголосував
всі ті закони які необхідні для
позитивного рішення щодо початку
перемовин про вступ України до ЄС
Шановні колеги Я дуже прошу щоб Отакі
результати єдності побачили ті хто
будуть приймати рішення 14 і 15го числа
саме в брюселі щодо України Я Дякую усім
за єдність я Дякую усім за високу
відповідальність при голосуванні за такі
важливі закони очевидно що ці закони
Верховна Рада мала би прийняти
давнимдавно а не залишати на останній
тиждень перед уже
історичним засіданням саміту євроради
запланованим в брюселі на 15 грудня ми
всі ці умови з літа минулого року чим Ми
займалися чому ми стільки часу не могли
виконати ці умови не дотягнули до
останнього моменту за тиждень до
засідання Європейської ради терміново
приймаємо а євроінтеграцію зайнялись
тільки коли вже петух клюнул в одне
місце мова іде про чотири законопроекти
перший - це про набу яким збільшується
кількість детективів на Буз 700 до 1000
цей процес буде тривати роки і мова
йдеться не лише про чисельність
антикорупційної інфраструктури мова
йдеться про забезпечення реальної
Незалежності мова йдеться про
забезпечення реальної контролю
громадськості і мова йдеться про
Забезпечення
ефективності другий важливий
законопроект - це сап - це посилення
інституційної спроможності і
Незалежності спеціалізованої
антикорупційної прокуратури яким сап
тепер Є окремим підрозділом
від Генеральної прокуратури оскільки він
повертає до побудови незалежної
підкреслюю ключове слово незалежної
антикорупційної інфраструктури яка була
створена в
14му1 роках нашою командою третій - це
зміни до Закону Про назк який дозволяє
національному
антикорупційному агентству з запобігання
корупції ряти майно декларантів нажити
ними і
до отримання статусу вже декларанта тому
що 80% українців говорять що боротьба з
корупцією є для них на другому місці
після безпекового питання тобто
настільки сьогодні вже накралися що самі
українці вимагають посилити боротьбу з
корупцією і звичайно в цьому контексті
дуже важливо аби боротьба з корупцією не
перетворилася тільки в боротьбу з
помилками в декларації чи деклараціях
Влада На жаль демонструє фасадну
боротьбу з корупцією а не реальну а для
того щоби боротьба з корупцією була
системною ловилася велика риба ті хто на
державному бюджеті сьогодні стають
новими курченками також серед
обов'язкових маяків Європейської комісії
які Нам необхідно було виконати для того
аби отримати позитивне рішення про
початок перемовин щодо членства це були
зміни до закону про на нацменшини
навколо цього законопроекту виник
справжній скандал нагадаю що уряд подав
до парламенту законопроект який просто
відкривав великий простір і лазівки для
насильницької такої знову повзучої
русифікації Шкода що ця робота почалася
лише після того як розроблений без
належної взаємодії з парламентом і
громадянським суспільством Урядовий
проект був поспішно зареєстрований і
викликав масове громадянське обурення що
вилилося у громадську компанію євро ція
без русифікації тут зразу такі пішли
емоції стефанчука його там
пости відверто хамські по відношенню до
нашої політичної сили але виявилося що
європейська Солідарність абсолютна права
і дуже дивно виглядали звинувачення
деяких очільників парламенту та уряду в
тому числі на мою персональну адресу
тому що і громадськість і депутати
європейської солідарності і представники
інших фракцій які піддали критиці
Урядовий проект чітко вказували на
неприйнятні норми в цьому проекті і
надали конкретні пропозиції як
вдосконалити цей текст я є співавтором
цього закону І він виконує рекомендації
венеційської комісії дозволяє навчання в
приватних вузах в приватних школах
мовами країн Європейського Союзу мовами
нацменшин дозволяє рекламу політичну
мовами нацменшин але з обов'язковим так
само добляжем українською дозволяє в
медіа якщо вони зареєстровані як медіа
нацменшин Ну наприклад нам очевидно
треба підтримувати кримськотатарську
мову і мати кримськотатарські медіа але
там також залишається частка української
мови І от ми внесли такі запобіжники що
мова йде виключно про мови країн
Європейського Союзу і нацменшин але це
неможливо ці позиції не розповсюджуються
на мову країниагресора принциповим для
нас була позиція
по забороні русифікації і руйнації тих
мовних законів які були були прийняті в
18му-19 роках саме тому ми наполягали
попередньо що ми не будемо
голосувати в цілому Якщо не будуть
враховані наші правки зараз я маю
констатувати що правки пропозиції
європейської солідарності враховані
сьогодні ще три народні депутати двоє
позафракційних це єфімов це шпенов які
представляють відродження України група
там на ашмтках опзж створена і
позапартійний а також Данилов це
представник батьківщини склали мандати
ну Подивіться до чого ми з вами дійшли
та від нас тікають люди Ну вже Вибачте
скоро пачками будем тут голосувать як
люди вже звідси йдуть та А що тут робити
в принципі я їх розумію до нас не ходеть
уряд до на ми державний бюджет приймаємо
до нас прем'єр-міністр не приходить То
що тут робить ми де година запитань до
уряду де я питаю
за 600 днів один раз один раз ми мали
тут пана шмигаля Да ми забули як він
виглядає тепер в парламенті залишається
лише 401 народний депутат це такий
історичний для Верховної Ради України
мінімум я нагадаю що згідно Конституції
в нас 450 народних депутатів парламент
знищений можна знаєте перейменувати нас
в Верховної ради на Україну вру на в
верховний Єрмак України він один може
бути за нас тут з вами бо він один в нас
працює я дивлюсь він у нас і Міністр
закордонних справ він і президент він і
прем'єр-міністр він все нинішній
парламент по суті деградує і
знецінюється А на жаль керівництво
парламенту дозволяє зовнішній тиск і
управління парламентом ну це ганьба
очевидно що ми не могли не зреагувати на
те свавілля керівництва парламенту СБУ
які за вказівкою офісу президента
сьогодні блокують міжпарламентську
діяльність депутатів європейської
солідарності і все це відбувається на
фоні очевидних дипломатичних неуспіхів
ну провалів або якихось помилок влади і
хотів би звернутися до чоловічої частини
Президії бо я дуже добре знаю всіх голів
Верховної Ради за 32 роки нашої
Незалежності ніхто як ви не множив на
ноль парламентаризм коли команда
європейської солідарності серед якої є
досвідчені мати люди які довели що вони
можуть вести успішні переговори і про
безвізовий режим і мирні переговори і
переговори про угоду про асоціацію
сьогодні по суті наша діяльність
блокується і це безглуззя в тому нема
жодного якогось пояснення це враження
таке як самоціль для когось хтось хоче
не захистити державу а бути черговим
таким героєм серіалу де тільки він тому
ми бачимо атаки і на залужного буквально
кілька днів тому чергова Атака від такої
знакової
члена слуг народу безуглої атака на
Порошенка і власне ці атаки ці політичні
інтриги це на сьогодні є
найбільший такий удар в спину для
української армії для українського
суспільст в Сполучених Штатах 30 слуг
поїхали туди за кошти держбюджету за
кошти бюджету і вони сьогодні тут
виступали в парламенті розказали що
привезли з штатів американських два
прапори перед вами два прапори які ми
плануємо передати Верховному
головнокомандувачу зеленському і
головнокомандувачу залужному які
підписали члени діючі військові
нацгвардій Каліфорнії Нацгвардії Арізони
підписали американці лідери релігійних
організацій різних конфесій діаспоряни
лідери бізнесскіл і також виробничих
потужностей Сполучених Штатів це дуже
круто привести два прапори за бюджетні
кошти прокататися Але я думаю що
Порошенко би привіз більш вагомі
результати зі Сполучених Штатів де нам
просто зірвали і
його спілкування і зустріч зі спікером
конгресу джонсоном із республіканцями з
конгресменами демократами
сенаторами в аналітичних центрах
пентагоні в деждепі хотіли вдарити по
мені а вдарили по Україні І за це треба
буде відповідати Петро Олексійович подав
уже звернувся до суду щодо такого
свавілля керівництва парламенту Ну і
наші депутати депутатки також го готують
такі позови ми не дозволимо знищити
парламентаризм і
дискредитувати незалежний інститут влади
дуже важливий в
парламентсько-президентській Республіці
тому що я вважаю що вся ця історія має
розслідуватися в порядку кримінального
провадження оскільки Я особисто вважаю
що тут є склад кримінальних
правопорушень і не одного також
парламент сьогодні прийняв рішення про
створення національного військового
кладовища в гатному в травні Верховна
Рада України прийняла законопро закон
уже
321м голосом народних депутатів про
створення національного меморіального
кладовища в биківні цей закон не був
підписаний президентом Зеленським і
зараз вносячи в порядок денний новий
законопроект про створення національного
кладовища в новому місті Ми створюємо
дуже небезпечний прецедент коли є закон
він вважається таким що вступив в силу
він не заветований президентом
Зеленським але голосується новий
законопроект при тому що проводилися
громадські слухання залучалися до них
родини загиблих героїв і з пафосом з
таким Міністерство культури Міністерство
ветеранів презентували це створення
кладовища в биківні потім все перекре
Лили І от чомусь вирішили створювати
таке кладовище цей меморіал в гатному
питання не тільки в не тільки в биківні
чи в биківні має бути кладовище чи у
фасівському районі хоча це важливо
питання Чому відбувається знучання з
родичів загиблих героїв яких ви не
хочете чути чому відбувається топтання
Конституції чому Міністерство культури
Міністерство ветеранів Та інші відомства
які активно агітували за біківню тепер
так само активно виступають проти коли
вони казали правду тоді чи тепер ми
отримались від цього голосування тому що
в першу чергу вважаємо що має тут бути
максимальна узгодженість таких дій в
такому делікатному питанні з самими
родинами загиблих Ну і звичайно ми
хочемо почути відповідь Ну що це таке
прийнято закон він не завитований але і
не підписаний давайте Приймемо якийсь
новий закон ми вважаємо що так взагалі
можна далеко піти і будь-який закон
потім переголосовувати тися разів без
зрозумілих причин відповідно до 94
четвертої статті Конституції ухвалений
нами у травні документ уже є законом
який цитую вважається схваленим
Президентом України і має бути
підписаний та офіційно оприлюднений і
потім у цей закон можна внести
відповідні зміни щоб давноми могли ми з
вами зробити замість того щоб догоджати
банкові друзі продовжимо інформувати вас
про роботу парламенту тому підписуйтеся
на наш YouTube канал Дивіться нас тут
багато важливої інформації і тут правда
про роботу Верховної Ради України все
буде Україна друзі